y
[Música]
se cumplen 80 días de guerra en ucrania
y continúa la ofensiva de las fuerzas
ucranianas que han forzado la retirada
de las tropas rusas de la ciudad de
kharkiv la segunda más grande del país
las autoridades de kiev aseguran que el
ejército de moscú ahora concentra su
ofensiva en la región de donges donde
continúan los ataques
en eeuu hay convocadas más de 300
movilizaciones en contra de la posible
decisión de la corte suprema- que podría
anular el derecho al aborto a nivel
federal las marchas llegan tras la
filtración de un borrador de sentencia
del tribunal supremo que aparentemente
acabaría con esta protección
corea del norte informó que en las
últimas 24 horas fueron detectados más
de 170 mil casos y 21 muertes
aparentemente por kobe 19 el líder del
país kim jong-un convocó una nueva
reunión para atender la situación que
tiene preocupada a la población
bienvenidos al nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos esta emisión en
ucrania puntualmente en la ciudad de
jarque la segunda más importante del
país tras semanas de intenso asedio por
parte de las fuerzas rusas las tropas
ucranianas han logrado replegar a los
soldados rusos según medios
internacionales el ejército de moscú
concentra ahora su ofensiva en retomar
terrenos que ha ido perdiendo en la
región del donbass más detalles en el
siguiente informe
en este pequeño suburbio del noreste
dejar que muchas cosas han quedado
reducidas de escombros las tropas rusas
han sido expulsadas de la zona y los
residentes han empezado a regresar
dichas zonas napster y libertad ahora no
nos bombardean sólo se dispara nuestra
artillería no hay impacto sobre nosotros
por lo tanto se puede vivir en paz el
agua y la electricidad han sido
recolectadas
clichy lingotto jarquín la segunda
ciudad de ucrania está situada apenas a
40 km de la frontera rusa y fue uno de
los primeros objetivos de los ataques
rusos en las últimas semanas las tropas
ucranianas empezaron a alejar a las
fuerzas rusas en la región hasta el
punto de que los residentes han
comenzado a regresar a la ciudad y sus
alrededores comensal típica en el
noreste de la ciudad dondequiera que
mires se puede recordar que hace sólo
unos días esto era parte de la primera
línea esto era un campo de batalla había
explosiones muy fuertes todos los días a
todas horas algunas personas al
principio querían quedarse aquí
protegiéndose en los refugios
subterráneos pero luego se dieron cuenta
de que era imposible quedarse aquí más
allá al este de la ciudad el pueblo de
vilque ipca los ciudadanos que viven
allí tratan de seguir adelante con sus
vidas pero quedó en su memoria los
recuerdos de la presencia rusa los
soldados rusos vivían aquí solían dormir
presuntamente durante la noche se
escondían aquí es como un búnker para
esconderse de los bombardeos dormían
aquí hay una cocina solían comer aquí lo
intentaban al menos
jarquín y sus alrededores tenían 15
millones de habitantes antes de la
invasión rusa ahora es menos de un
tercio de eso
el presidente ucraniano volodymyr
selenski aseguró que se está haciendo
todo lo posible por evacuar a los
soldados ucranianos que se encuentran
sitiados en la acería de azov tal el
último bastión de la resistencia en la
ciudad de mariupol el mandatario señaló
que aunque se llevan a cabo
negociaciones para una evacuación no
existe confianza en la delegación rusa
desde jarc y leticia álvarez enviada
especial de france 24 nos da más
detalles
se les que está intentando hacer todo lo
posible para negociar en la evacuación
del batallón de azov que todavía resiste
en la acería mariupol lleva siendo
ocupada por el ejército ruso desde hace
casi más de un mes pero esos
combatientes resisten en la acería y hay
muchos que están heridos y necesitan ser
evacuados fuertemente sin embargo su
viceministra ya ha avisado que estas
negociaciones no van a ser fáciles y se
muestra pesimista porque en las
negociaciones van a tener que hacer
concesiones y esto no va a gustar a todo
el mundo piden también la ayuda de
europa y de la comunidad internacional
para poder mediar en esta situación la
acería de mariupol
resiste después de dos meses en esta
invasión rusa y se ha convertido ya en
un icono en todo este país en ucrania y
el presidente de volodymyr selenski
recibió también este sábado al líder
republicano del senado de eeuu mitch
mcconnell quien llegó junto con una
comisión de legisladores el mandatario
señaló que se trata de una poderosa
señal de apoyo bipartidista a ucrania
por parte del congreso de los eeuu y el
pueblo estadounidense asimismo señaló
que el gobierno de washington está
ayudando a ucrania a luchar por los
valores y las libertades democráticas
por su parte el ministro de asuntos
exteriores de rusia serguéi lávrov habló
en el consejo de diplomacia y defensa
del país y aseguró que occidente ha
comenzado una guerra híbrida contra
rusia y que es difícil predecir cuánto
durará los esfuerzos para aislar a rusia
aseguró están condenados al fracaso
en el occidente en conjunto nos ha
declarado una guerra híbrida total y es
difícil predecir cuánto durará todo esto
pero está claro que las consecuencias
las sentirán todos sin excepción hicimos
todo lo posible para evitar un
enfrentamiento directo pero ahora que el
desafío ha sido lanzado por supuesto que
lo aceptamos no somos ajenos a las
sanciones casi siempre estuvieron ahí de
una forma u otra ciudad y en medio de la
tensión por el deseo de ingreso de
finlandia en la otan el presidente
finlandés conversó con vladimir putin
para comunicarle los planes de su
gobierno a su vez el mandatario ruso le
respondió que abandonar el estatus
neutral sería un grave error para muchos
de los que viven cerca de la frontera
oriental finlandesa con rusia la noticia
ha sido recibida con alivio finlandia se
ha mantenido neutral en el pasado pero
la opinión pública ha dado un giro
radical a favor de la adhesión a la otan
tras la invasión de ucrania por parte de
moscú la localidad de imatra está a unos
pocos kilómetros de rusia y mantiene una
complicada relación con su vecino vamos
con el informe
a pocos kilómetros de la frontera con
rusia se encuentra en la ciudad
finlandesa de imatra el nerviosismo por
la invasión rusa de ucrania se ha
sentido más aquí que en otros lugares de
finlandia con muchos residentes
aliviados por la intención del país de
unirse a la otan lo turbado estado es
seguro vivir aquí pero cuando empezó la
guerra en ucrania empecé a preguntarme
que si algún día estaríamos en la misma
situación ya que estamos tan cerca de la
frontera
deberíamos habernos unido antes no tiene
sentido alargarlo más llevamos años
viendo lo que pasa en el exterior
incluso antes de la guerra de ucrania y
mattrah tenía una relación complicada
con rusia los dolorosos recuerdos de la
invasión rusa durante la segunda guerra
mundial todavía están presentes
pero siempre se ha temido a rusia a lo
largo de los tiempos siempre hemos
estado de alerta y hemos desconfiado una
de las euro lamento está pero en esta
zona tenemos interacciones todos los
días
alrededor de mil residentes tienen la
nacionalidad rusa y muchos cruzaban la
frontera con regularidad antes de que se
cerrara a una distancia de 210 km san
petesburgo están más cerca de la ciudad
que la capital finlandesa helsinki pero
un enlace ferroviario previsto entre la
ciudad rusa y mattrah y muchos otros
proyectos transfronterizos se han
cancelado por la guerra
y nos vamos hasta eeuu donde hay
convocadas más de 300 movilizaciones a
favor del derecho al aborto legal el
descontento social ha crecido en el país
luego de que se filtrara un borrador de
sentencia de la corte suprema de
justicia que podría anular la icónica
sentencia del caso roe versus wade que
protege el derecho a la interrupción
voluntaria del embarazo a nivel federal
para analizar esta jornada de
movilizaciones hablamos previamente con
hamels y rodríguez presidenta del plan
parent hood de missouri sobre si la
actual administración de joe biden es
capaz de proteger el derecho al aborto
en el país
lo que es importante que reconozcamos
ahora mismo es que estamos en un punto
de inflexión en el curso de la historia
de los derechos sexuales y reproductivos
y una de las cosas que queremos que sea
bien visible en el día de hoy es que le
estamos demandando a todos las personas
que están en el poder en el gobierno
incluyendo a la administración del
presidente martín que tomen todo tipo de
acción necesaria para continuar
proveyendo de optando nos la oportunidad
nosotros que proveemos servicios de
salud a continuar el acceso seguro y
legal al aborto en los eeuu es bien
importante que las personas me entiendan
y esto es una carrera a largo plazo que
tenemos que continuar el momento y que
tenemos que lanzarnos a la boleta de
votación porque ahí es donde va a
comenzar el cambio real
y corea del norte informó que en las
últimas 24 horas fueron detectados más
de 170 mil casos y 21 muertes por lo que
las autoridades han calificado de una
fiebre de origen desconocido
aparentemente asociada al cove' y 19 el
país comienza a tomarse con seriedad los
contagios registrados por kobe 19 y el
líder del país kim jong-un convocó una
nueva reunión para atender la situación
que tiene preocupada a la población le
contamos en el siguiente informe
dos días después del anuncio oficial del
primer caso de kobe 19 en corea del
norte kim jong-un ha convocado una
segunda reunión de emergencia las cifras
no son claras y faltan medios de
detención del virus las autoridades
hablan de 500.000 casos de fiebre desde
finales de abril sin precisar el número
exacto de contagios de kobe 19 este
sábado el líder norcoreano calificó la
situación de grave para el país ninguno
de los 25 millones de habitantes está
vacunado contra el coronavirus ya que
desde pyongyang se rechazó las ofertas
de la organización mundial de la salud
de china y de rusia según este experto
correa del norte podría abrirse a la
ayuda internacional
es posible que hayan revelado estos
casos intencionalmente con el fin de
abrir nuevas opciones como reconsiderar
la adquisición de vacunas kóvacs o
recibir la ayuda internacional con gran
ganga
hasta
ahora del norte cerró sus fronteras en
enero del 2020 tras del rebrote de casos
por comido en china el país no envió
atletas a los juegos olímpicos de tokio
y pekín algo por lo que siempre sabían
enorgullecido es de mantener a raya la
pandemia las autoridades ordenan ahora
una contención drástica de la población
los norcoreanos están temerosos por el
coi y el ambiente en el país se ha
puesto tenso entonces para elevar la
moral de la población es probable que
corea del norte acelere nuevas pruebas
de misiles
tan cansina las imágenes de satélite
indican que corea del norte se está
preparando para realizar una prueba
nuclear y que podría tener lugar este
mismo mes según los eeuu
vamos a emiratos árabes unidos- allí el
consejo supremo federal del país eligió
al emir de abu dhabi mohamed bin zayed
al nahyan como nuevo presidente el
nombramiento se produce un día después
de que su hermanastro y anterior jefe de
estado- jalifa bin zayed al-nahyan
falleciera a los 73 años el nuevo
mandatario expresó su agradecimiento por
la confianza de los líderes mandatarios
occidentales como el presidente
estadounidense joe biden anunciaron que
ya conversaron con el presidente para
desearle éxitos
y en turín al norte de italia se
llevaron a cabo los últimos ensayos de
cara a la final del festival de
eurovisión cuyo ganador se conocerá en
la noche de este sábado el grupo
ucraniano kalus orchestra es el favorito
para llevarse al concurso otros 24
países participan en la final de este
evento televisivo que atrae a hasta 200
millones de telespectadores más detalles
con el siguiente informe
la orquestra k luz de ucrania pretende
levantar el ánimo de sus compatriotas
ucranianos con una victoria
su canción stefan es interpretada en
ucraniano y fusiona el rap con música
folclórica tradicional las casas de
apuestas la han convertido en la clara
favorita
la canción estefanía fue escrita mucho
antes de que estallara la guerra estaba
dedicada a mi madre pero después de que
empezara la guerra la gente le dio un
nuevo significado porque piensan en la
madrugá nea por eso estaban cerca del
corazón de muchos ucranianos a muchos
europeos también les gustaba
rusia está excluida debido a la guerra
en ucrania
los fans de eurovisión están en la
ciudad anfitriona de turing para gritar
por su favorito entre los 25 finalistas
[Música]
bien
medita
[Música]
pide trabajo bien estaba bien y trabajo
estrada
estos aficionados franceses consideran
que serbia tiene la mejor canción con
este tema de la cantante contracto
[Aplausos]
la decisión final en eurovisión se
divide entre un jurado profesional y el
público
si ucrania gana estocolmo se ha ofrecido
a acoger el evento del año próximo en el
caso de que la guerra continúe
y hasta aquí este repaso a las
principales noticias de la actualidad
internacional les invitamos a que sigan
conectados a france 24 y les recordamos
que pueden ampliar toda esta hay mucha
más información en nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom
[Música]